هدوء حذر يسود شوارع مدينه بلغراد وقلق
متواصل في منطقه باتت عرضه للقصف
الاوكراني الذي استهدف حتى مركز المدينه
في وقت سابق بحسب السلطات الروسيه
ما حدث كان خطيرا للغايه فالنازيون عبروا
حدودنا الحمد لله قواتنا سيطرت على الوضع
مشيت
لا يجب ان يحدث ذلك على اراضينا فلابد ان
يكون مواطنون محميين
تلقي العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا بظلالها بالدرجه الاولى على
المناطق الحدوديه الروسيه فتاره تقصف
المدن والقرب المدفعيه وتاره اخرى تشن
القوات الاوكرانيه هجمات عليها بمسيارات
تطال المراكز الاداريه والبنيه التحتيه
بحسب وزاره الدفاع واصطم مخاوفه من انتقال
الحربي الى الداخل الروسي القصف الاوكراني
للمدن والقرى الحدوديه في مقاطعه بيل جارد
لا يتوقف منذ اشهر لكن الاهم حاليا
بالنسبه للسلطات هنا هو حمايه الحدود
الروسيه لاسيما بعد اختراقها من قبل
مجموعات مسلحه تواجه موسكو الاتهام بشانها
الى كيف
عمل ارهابي هكذا قيمت موسكو الهجوم الذي
ارتكبته وحدات من التشكيلات القوميه
الاوكرانيه بحق المدنيين في مقاطعه بلغراد
وفقا لمعطيات الدفاع الروسيه هجوم جاء بعد
تهديدات للسكرتير مجلس الامن القومي
الاوكراني توعد فيها بتنفيذ عمليات عسكريه
في المناطق الحدوديه الروسيه
الهدف من العمليه بتقدير كان بالدرجه
الاولى للتاثير الاعلامي اي لصرف الانتباه
عن الضربه المعنويه والسياسيه الحساسه
التي تلقتها بعد سيطره القوات الروسيه على
باغموت وهذا ما حدث واخبار مقاطعه بيلغرود
اصبحت الخبر الاول على الشاشات بينما
اخبار ضخمه الثانويه
في خضم هذه الاحداث باشرت السلطات المحليه
دراسه الخيارات القانونيه لتسليح وحدات
الدفاع الاقليمي التي انشات منذ اكثر من
عام للدفاع عن المنطقه في حال انتقال
الصراع الى الاراضي الروسيه وحدات تتالف
حاليا من نحو ثلاثه الاف شخص ترى السلطات
ان بامكانها لعب دور بناء في حمايه سكان
المناطق الحدوديه من اي تطورات طارئه رنا